Why at this late date, are
the heads of social media platforms
still denying
their platforms roles in
causing the teen mental health crisis?
This week, Metters
Mark Zuckerberg was one of five
tech leaders
to testify at a Senate hearing
about the protection of children
from online sexual exploitation.
In a dramatic moment,
Zuckerberg turned to face
an apologize to dozens of parents
holding up photos of their teens
whose deaths they blamed on social media.
But in a prepared statement,
he still maintain that his platforms,
Facebook and Instagram,
did not bear any direct responsibility.
With so much of our lives
spent on mobile devices and social media,
it's important to look into the effects
on teen mental health and well-being.
I take this very seriously.
Mental health is a complex issue
and the existing body of scientific work
has not shown a causal link
between using social media
and young people having
worse mental health outcomes.
In response,
GOP Senator Josh
Hawley of Missouri
quoted the company's own in-house study
that had been leaked by whistleblower
Francis Horgan
to the Wall Street Journal.
But Zuckerberg
didn't budge from his position.
Here's a quote from your own study quote
We make body image issues
worse for one in three teen girls.
Here's another quote.
Teens blame Instagram.
This is your study
for increases in the rate of anxiety
and depression.
This reaction was unprompted
and consistent across all groups.
That's your study.
Senator.
We try to understand the
the feedback
and how people feel about the services
we can improve.
Wait a minute.
You're always out of your own.
Study says
that you make life worse
for one in three teenage girls.
You increase anxiety and depression.
That's what it says.
And you're here
testifying to us in public
that there's no link.
You've been doing this for years.
Full speed ahead.
While internally you know full
well your product is a disaster
for teenagers.
Jean Tanguy joins me now.
She's the author of
I Gen and Generations
and a professor of psychology
at San Diego State University.
Dr. Huang, great to have you back.
I remember when we first spoke,
when I gen came out in 2017,
we had the dialog on my radio show
and here
then you were hesitant to use the word
causation.
You spoke more in terms of correlation.
What has changed
since your book came out?
Yes, So that was in 2017
and since then
we have seen a lot more studies.
So Zuckerberg's statement
about not knowing about
causation is simply wrong.
At this point,
there are many studies
showing that there is a causal link.
So these are done like drug trials.
There's a treatment group
and a control group,
and it's random who ends up in which one
and a treatment group.
You give up social media
or cut back on social media versus
the control group, continuing normal use
and those who have cut back or given up
social media after two or three weeks
are happier and less depressed.
And there's also specific
studies on Instagram.
You show teen girls and young women
as perfect bodies on Instagram,
they influencers
and they have worse body image.
After seeing that
compared to a control group.
You're part of a very
important collaboration.
I'm going to put it on the screen
and have you explain what
this is yourself.
It's Jonathan Haidt.
By the way, I finished last night.
His new forthcoming book
directly on this subject.
It's tremendous.
And Zach Roush,
what is it
that the three of you have done?
What am I showing the world now
in this collaborative Google doc?
Yeah.
So a few years ago,
we put our heads together
and decided, you know, we need to compile
all the research in this area
of that experimental research
I mentioned,
as well
as the correlational research
on tens of thousands of genes.
And many countries
know that
the more hours a day
a team spent on social media,
the more likely it is
that they're going to be depressed.
There's also longitudinal studies.
They're following people over time.
Plus, we have another Google dog
on the team mental health crisis
that, for example,
pain, depression
doubled between 2011 and 2019.
So it's not due to the pandemic.
This increase started eight years
before the pandemic.
Probably not a coincidence
right at the time that social media
started to become much more commonly used
among teens.
Also, around the time Facebook,
Instagram
and smartphones
started to have front facing cameras.
So these image based sites became
so much more popular.
You know that some say, hey, it's
COVID, it's
the economy, it's climate change,
it's school shootings.
So you, Dr.
Twang, a year ago
published I'll put this up on the screen.
You published an analysis of 13
other possible explanations.
And then with data,
you ruled them all out.
Although there's one that's tantalizing,
that's alternative number six.
I'm putting that up on the screen
right now.
That's the
it's because children and teens
have less independence.
Of the 13 that get bandied about.
This one you thought
might have some merit.
And I guess you actually
read these together
a different parenting style
and the age of technology.
Explain.
Yes.
And first,
I want to point out that one reason
a lot of those other 12 explanations
fail is that they're focused
just on the US,
things
like the political climate
or school shootings.
But it turns out that
that increase
in depression
and loneliness among teens is worldwide.
It shows up in international data
as country after country.
Very little happens until 2012.
And then depression
and anxiety and loneliness
goes to the rich.
So that explanation around independence,
it's true that teens now, compared
to previous generations,
less likely to get their driver's license
by the end of high school,
they're less likely to date
and less likely to have a paid job.
They go out without their parents
a lot less
than previous generations did
when they were in high school.
This is how Gen Z lives.
And it's not just about
a parenting style.
This is a huge cultural trend
across all ages
that we just simply take longer
to grow up and longer to grow old.
It's called this.
Take my.
Final yes.
Take my final 30 seconds.
Go back to where we began.
Why doesn't Zuckerberg get it?
Surely he knows your book,
your books,
the seminal book on the subject.
Surely he has seen
what you and and Heit have put together
and the Google doc and the collaboration.
Why?
Why does he stand that ground?
Because this is their business.
This is how they make money.
If they decided it's
not career,
decide, okay, I want to keep kids safe.
We're going to raise the minimum age
for being on Instagram to 16
and actually verify age.
They know what will happen.
All of their young users
will go to tick tock and other platforms
and they make an enormous amount of money
off of teens,
even off of the 12 and under kids
who aren't supposed to be on there
at all.
Under the law,
they are making money on our kids time
and attention
and on the backs of their mental health.
Thank you, Dr.
Twanging.
Thank you.
Social media reaction.
That sounds odd to this conversation.
Let's see
what the world of Twitter has said.
No, I question the parents.
Why did you let them watch
or use social media in the first place?
Okay, Magna.
Let me respond to that.
Sorry, but it was your child
because how do I say this
in in a short time period?
And having just finished
Jonathan's book last night,
because if you are the parent
who says,
I'm not going to allow my son
or my daughter
to have access to social media,
you've now made them the social outcast,
right?
Because not all parents
are going to be able to do that.
And consequently,
the few who do aren't
going to be socially interacting
behind closed doors
with their thumbs
with the other kids,
because that's how prevalent
it has become.
So you can't just say, oh, it's it's
the parents.
It's not just the parents,
because the parents
who try to do
what you've
advocated are going to ostracize
their own kids socially.